l'ex travailleuse sociale et j'ai
travaillé dans la politique à une époque
et je suis tombé malade il disait quand
on est malade je me suis retrouvé à les
demander ces aides et ça a été hyper
douloureux pour moi en fait ces
qualités c'est
angie je peux pas payer ça moi non pas
du tout moi ça fait qu'on mois et non
autour de la table on n'a pas tous des
bons salaires mon cher bruno de choix et
les gentils l'humiliation
les services dans notre pays ça crée un
clivage choc inédit et qui est hyper
dangereux la communauté de citoyens que
nous sommes
alors c'est vrai que ça c'était
raymond c'est ce que j'ai dit à l'heure
pour pour noël c'est ce que j'ai dit
pour les gens qui doivent regarder leurs
enfants dans les yeux que les hôtes ont
eu eux ont pas c'est une humiliation tu
as des gens ils veulent pas se servir
des aides ils veulent pas les
allocations familiales s'ils veulent ils
disent tous temps je m'en sortir tout
seul ils se cachent ils disent pas leur
famille qui a rien dans le frigo ils
sont fiers et ils essaient de s'en
sortir par eux mêmes et c'est très dur
alors live web vraiment les démagos si
vous voulez mais c'est des gens qui
existe il existe dans mon entourage si
on peut aider on est autant qu'on peut
mais voilà c'est quoi la question
sommes-nous forcément riche en tout cas
quand on a la télé on n'est pas pauvre
parce que les salaires qui sont à la
télé c'est pas des salaires que tu
retrouves quand tu vas travailler à
l'usiné ou ailleurs ou je ne sais je
sais je le dis souvent on le sait nous
entends chroniqueurs on est quand même
on est quand même bien privilégiées par
rapport aux autres guillot enfin nous on
est privilégié c'est vrai mais après la
télé c'est comme plein de métiers et par
exemple les avocats ya des avocats très
riche et des avocats qui sont à l'enjeu
du tout et en télé aujourd'hui le
problème c'est que la télé c'est un
métier tellement attractif pour plein de
gens il ya tellement de gens qui rêvent
de faire de la télé qui seraient prêts à
le faire gratuitement et la réalité nous
on a de la chance ici on est très bien
payé mais sur des chaînes de la tnt vous
avez des mecs six chroniqueurs qui sont
payés 100 euros brut ils font une
chronique par semaine
par jour elle raconte calmement je sois
parti même sens qu'à quelques semaines
mais la chaleur se cache pas ce que tu
vas pas le dire non tu va choisir tu vas
faire coquillettes rico tiens tu vas tu
vas pas et flamber et tu vas dire tout
va bien c'est les actes quand vous posez
la question aux gens la plupart du temps
vous en foutez de la réponse ça va tu
demandais aux gens ça va tu t'en fous de
sa réponse on est passé à autre chose la
personne avant le second tour
la personne à votre réponse est oui ça
va oui elle va te réponds que ça va même
si elle a découvert de 500 balles elle
sait qu'elle a pas d'eau zahia sait pas
quand elle va te dire en par louis saha
batteur benjamin
non mais ça m'arrive c'est serré
clermont on n'est pas d'accord
évidemment quand on est à la télévision
tous les jours on n'a pas la même vie
que tout le monde ça c'est indéniable on
est d'accord pas aimer mais c'est pas
parce qu'ils gagnent plus d'argent que
je veux pas être dans des difficultés
extrêmement période extrêmement
compliqué que le pour le premier et je
le dis à chaque fois le premier à gré
mais elle est bien le problème est le
même pour tout le monde pretoria vial
quand tu davis que tu gagnes 100 euros
1000 euros ou 10000 euros le muguet la
mégane i call est la même et que tu est
broyé de la même fin septembre après
c'est pas audible évidemment moi je vous
parle pour moi jamais parce que j'ai eu
la chance d'avoir une vie incroyable et
j'ai très bien travaillé très bien
gagner ma vie il m'est arrivé ce qui
m'est arrivé de ma faute ou pas c'est
même pas le problème et je le vis très
bien mais je trouve ça c'est ya des gens
sans parler des gens de télé qui est une
bien leur vie un jour il ya un pépin et
ces gens-là ce jour là quand ça décroche
sa dette il faut pouvoir entendre que sa
décrue et quand ça d'écran je crois moi
et moi je serai jamais pleurer dans les
chaumières c'est très compliqué à vis ma
vie même quand tu as eu des milliers de
francs même des millions d'euros et que
tout d'un coup y'a plus rien qui
fonctionne que tu as plus de carte bleue
et c'est le bordel il est le même et moi
j'y crois j'adore voir quant à la fin du
mois tu peux plus mettre de de pétrole
dans la dans la queue dans la chaudière
et que de vraiment il fait 15 degrés
c'est toi et que tu étais en faut des
buts et drogba pas dit bye-bye je peux
pas mettre de pétrole dans la truck
c'est pareil pour tous a effectivement
j'étais donc 600 m² pas choper compliqué
à chauffer mais c'est pareil que dans
trente mètres carrés j'avais pas de
chauffeur à la maison mais si je dis ça
j'ai sûrement faire hurler la fois chez
toi et tu m'a expliqué ce point de vue
là il m'a expliqué son point de vue
quand je suis arrivé chez lui parce qu
on est souvent en s'embrouillait sur les
salaires se lisait les riches match
aller on était opposé il m'a expliqué
son point de vue et pour un mec comme
moi c'est pour toi c'est normal parce
que tu expliquer quand tu décroches plus
tu es riche plus les dépenses sont
beaucoup et pour un mec comme moi
c'était pas laisser le titre comprenant
des dépréciations plus importantes pour
moi c'était pas entendable parce que moi
je me disais on t'a pas dans ma tête
quand je lui ai même dit on s'en est
parlé en face on n'a pas demandé
d'acheter une farine on tape a demandé
d'acheter 1 600 m² si on tape a demandé
d'acheter un besoin de 1000 euros non
pas par des cimes refaire laissant messi
on t'a pas de misère d'investir mais
c'était ça le truc qui était possible de
voir ce que pour 15 h mais si jean
benjamin je finis les uns ou 15 40 pour
quelqu'un qui a pas d'argent c'est pas
entendable de dire il emballe ses portes
aux dîmes de dire il a mis 500 balles
lundi au niveau des leçons qu'on le fond
je le fais 30000 aux 30 minutes jamais
points quand le mec je dis je décroche
on est à décrocher mes thèmes 40000
euros dans une un gars deux ans un peu
pour tout à l'heure je suis et je serai
jamais d'accord avec toi et c'est pas le
poème d'acheter surtout parce qu'il a
fait une mégane explique-t-on tard pépin
la mégane tu vas le monde pareil que la
ferrari n arrêtait pas c'est un jeudi
par mois super sympa 80000 euros sur les
gags ne devrait décrocher pareil tu ton
c'est une question de proportion
non moi je veux la gageure que chez
raymond pardon évidemment c'est que le
prime de ce pays aussi c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tu vous nous rendait
coupable non par de basses histoire moi
on est obligé de dire on a peur de dire
parfois qu'on aime conviennent bien
famille qu'on a de l'argent dans les
show n'est pas évident j'ai la
télévision mais parfois gagner de
l'argent ça veut pas dire que tu es
quelqu'un de mal ça veut dire que tu
t'es battu pour l'avoir et que parfois
tu vois autour de ces noirs avec par
exemple on est ni chroniqueur bien sûr
qu'on a beaucoup de chance mais merde
y'a pas que de l'argent est aussi
chroniqueur et un animateur
de la chaleur il travaille plus la
chance aussi merde si on a peut-être
aussi sait combien les zones classées
qu'elles à 550 qui rêverait qu attendre
que le téléphone sonne quand tu fais de
la télé etc attendent que ça sonne et ça
sonne pas et ça sonne pour nous aussi
peut-être parce qu'on s'est battus
peut-être parce qu'on a bien bossé et
peut-être pas de caution le mérite
arrêtez tout le temps aussi de le
culpabiliser en permanence j'ai du mal à
entendre les jérémiades de mes collègues
et amis les balades
me saute pas dessus la non mais c'est
fini on va papa l'a plus jamais dû finir
et du mal à entendre benjamin dire que
c'était dur dans ce sens mais la
réussite était différée mais adam mais
j'en avais je peux bien faire
heureuse je dis la vérité vient jamais
délaissé m'attend sait même pas ce que
je vais dire que tu fais une connerie
c'est sûr
j'ai du mal à vous entendre vous plaint
d'avoir été riche et de ne plus la jso
club du ségala et les soirées monde du
dessin animé puis je trouve que pour
tous les gens qui sont les travailleurs
pauvres qui n'arrive
il arrête il a rien compris à ce qu'on a
expliqué rien du tout alors je dois être
rien y compris par expliquez-lui baïda
écoute moi une bonne fois pour toute et
on va voir si comprendre c'est pas
simple et riche ou pauvre ouvrier vous
prend par un élu et puisque tu dis qu'il
coûtait quoi
quand un problème de vie quand un
accident de vie que ce soit de ta faute
ou pas que tu sois à 10 15 20 une 30000
de décrochage est le même et le procédé
qui te broye et le même va m'écouter
aurait découvert il ya des gens mais
jamais
les toits mathieu tu as une boîte qui
marche bien tu es là tu brilles tu crois
que tu vas me faire pleurer un ton truc
j'ai plus d'emploi j'ai pu le dock
arrêter les foyers dit non à temps et
est dit
[Applaudissements]
arrêtez
la vérité quand ça s'est arrêté pour toi
tu es pmp pendant un an mais que je te
ramener en bagnole écouter et que tu me
tues tu tues moi tu m'a ramené il faut
emballer auraient deux fois s'est pas
fait payer l'essence
était digne d'un gardien des bagnoles
wac et était mal et où en bagnole
arrêtent de rêver on achète la voulais
me chauffer ou quoi
mathieu battu
melanie south stp mpc cet aîné rata l'a
pas fait j'étais en panique tu avais
plus de salaire était en panique c'était
compliqué qu est ce que tu te pardonne
inquiet de ma chance c'est pas là que
pour la question est de vous plaindre
guy boucher à un moment où ce plan qui
te plaît
[Applaudissements]
c'est que c'est que devant les caméras
tu te punit pas du tout baigné mais dans
ma voiture à la plus grosse était
d'amasser des caméras qui durera 10 gt
machin tu étais en plus heureuse qu'est
ce que je vais faire le suivi non mais
tu m'a ramené un état major
cité mérite parce qu'il ne comprend pas
ce que j'examine ensemble que c'est pas
de se plaindre le problème c'est que
quand un problème si besoin la mécanique
allait la même eau que ça veut dire
qu'ils cherchent ou
non c'est vous c'est très moche
ça veut dire quoi de votre foi la foi
qu'on ne sait pas ce téléphone quand tu
décroches quand ça décroche quand ça va
mal le principe est le même pour tout le
monde ainsi leur soient riches moyens
maurice coup très riche il est à des
entrées sur des problèmes et ils ont des
galères de vivre vous pouvoir l'entendre
sa l'état des gens très pauvres cons et
galère aussi mais ne permet à mécanique
est la même alors évidemment tu veux pas
pleurer pour ceux qui ont beaucoup à
meucon bien vécu effectivement mois par
pleurer pour eux mais la mécanique
allait là même en cas d'accord et jin
abe oui ou non il ya une vraie
différence c'est vrai que
[Musique]
tu nous racontes
c'est que on peut te te rétorqué qu'il
fallait mettre de côté tu avais les
moyens s'est offert ses larmes et
éviter gâteau elle entend tenir je suis
désolé mais à un moment tu le dis toi
même nom mais on peut pas entendre ça
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais pas se laisser
des gens juste là on a reçu j'ai des
gens qui avaient une situation très très
confortable sur ce plateau qui avait
effectivement une belle situation et qui
un jour où il ya un problème ils avaient
une maison il y avait des voitures et il
avait un restaurant et d'un an et un
jour il avait plus rien alors il a dû
faire quoi ça met de côté fallait
prévoir une galère
elles ont des leçons de vie de gens
savent aussi les trois images avaient
monté une boîte qui nous a donné un
salaire est jamais rien créé au moins 20
salariés tous les mois c'est qu'ils
n'ont jamais rien fait dix jours le cul
posé qui 2d de leçon sur comment
l'économie en france marque leader a dû
mettre de côté mais on a dû réussir
c'est peut-être même
[Applaudissements]
possibilité je suis désolé je suis
pas de risque comme boudeuse qu'on le
cul posé
jeudi jusqu'au combat de chez nous les
payons chaque année la personne qui n'a
jamais dit on on en parle depuis tout à
l'heure des gens qui travaillent ouais
parce que j'aime pas mathieu quand tu
dis mais oui mais j'ai beaucoup bossé
mais imagine un infirmier il a fait des
études et ses débuts sur les 120 mètres
carrés y aurait pas de crèches irait pas
d'exclure est pas tout ça c'est qu'on me
payer d'impôts
mais moi je voyais premier pays d'infos
je vivais avec lui j'avais sa feuille ne
pas faire un parallèle entre le travail
et bien gagner sa vie il ya des gens qui
bossent énormément donc c'est vous qui
le faites
si la bimbo c'est comme ce sera sans
nous informer pour la pour un dixième de
cent et tant mieux pour toi en plus tu n
as qu être que dans 16 mai mais
simplement on ne peut pas mettre en
parallèle ces choses là je sais ça ça
gène humain car il savait que j'étais à
gagner mais moi je comprends très bien
tout ce qu'elle dit est ce que même ce
même ce que depuis jean je vois même ray
que ça que sa révolte des gens mais je
vous explique jusque sabots ont révolté
effectivement il ya des réflexes fictive
oduya babala ils avaient qu'à mettre de
côté vous avez certainement raison et
bien vous avez raison mais
malheureusement la vie du mal à fait
ainsi et malheureusement quand il se
passe un problème dans ta vie quel que
soit ce que ton passage et décroche et
bah quand ça va plus durer comme ça mais
je n'ai pas tué mais les voitures des
croquis et voilà et après le mécanique
elle est là mêmes qui étaient dans la
rue le comparer mais après tout ce que
vous disiez c'est bien fait pour sa
gueule et des caméras
ça revient au même
zolpan garder les rides ou faire pleurer
voilà gilles jacquier déjà les vois pas
ce que vous pensez tous les deux qu'on
ait des riches tout ça c'est déjà là
quand tu montes une boîte qui battait
agressivité mal à l'aise toi
non mais bon qui laisse le cuir va tu
vas tu es toi tu quand tu vas voir une
banque au début que tu montes une boîte
elle vaut rien ta boîte tu vas voir une
banque et ludique au début tu veux pas
peut-être cent mille euros de découvert
pour pouvoir payer des salaires pouvoir
monter une boîte pour prendre des
risques la banque est un support au
début il ya pas marqué de leurs mots tpm
paix machin elle n'y croit pas forcément
au début tu prends des risques tu as des
nuits blanches et essaie de monter ta
boîte de pas de casser la gueule tu
travaille jour et nuit tu travailles 40
mais 40 heures mais pas par semaine mais
mais mais père joue pour que ta boîte et
le marché tu vois ce que je veux dire
qu'elle a tué quand ça commence à
marcher pour toi mais là franchement
mais voilà donc indécent des gens vous
qui sont assez quoi
ce que tu vas en mer mais c'est
l'expression merde quand je dis les bras
m'en tombent mes bras tombe pas bons
ballons
jeu de cyril deux ans et quand vous avez
suivi un f2 ou un château en mouvement
quand vous le prof vous êtes dehors dans
la rue pareil et quand quand on décroche
c'est pareil ça c'est quoi leur outil
c'est vrai qu'on voyait l'accord permet
la descente aux enfers et elles mêmes
pour tout le monde voilà et c'est pas et
je prenais la voiture en exemple quand
on vous pour votre bagnole c'est une
ferrari une mégane voilà à la fin tu
appuies bagnols donc voilà donc c'est la
même chose ça même histoire cela que je
suis pas d'accord mais voilà dix ans aux
enfers des 100 kw à court terme ne dit
rien et les coulées côté lavier sont en
rien des jeux coûtent jamais descendu
j'aimerais bien des
univers les origines quand on est à
prendre le flingue me charger elle met
en ratant pas en disant non mais ce que
je fais ce que je veux je vais pas tu
penses à des enfants effectivement la
laisse au delà des centrales est un peu
dur ferme ta gueule main exactement
ce que j'ai déjà raconté bien sûr que
son très bon oeil à la baisse et c'est
bon c'est pas si loin l'aja pouvait
pleurer voilà là ils coupent leur
effectivement quand tu te tue à cause de
ça il ya de quoi pleurer c'est pas drôle
mais j'ai pleuré pas maintenant pour
faire plaisir voilà une était pas tué on
est bien d'accord
des membres douloureux et le pape pour
qui on aurait compris tarifs adulte s'il
vous plaît
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après le jeu
j'aimerais j'aimerais juste tempérer les
choses parce que je te comprends tout à
fait mais je comprends aussi gilles ma
question est quand on a de l'argent
d'accord on peut prendre un appartement
à 600 mètres carrés une fois qu'on voit
qu'on a plus d'argent parce que ça se
passe pas comme ça le décrochage ok ça
décrochement 1,40 relativement peu d'y
remédier je préfère avoir un 70 m²
chauffer 1 600 m² froid je suis désolé
parce que en fait dans sa 600 m² tu peux
mettre cinq familles donc c'est quoi
est-ce que c'est l'ego qui te ferait
cédant 1 600 mètres carrés mais j'ai
froid excuse moi je trouve les fumées tu
dis des bêtises et non non
tu peux paris
la maison les saisies tu as fait une loi
folle à vendre la maison tu fais quoi ta
baraque tu fais quoi les tul à l'aise
comme ça que tu apprendras carbone
terrestre quand tu peux même plus tiré
sans mal à la carte bleue protéger ce
que tu dis là bas pour aider les gens
qui vendent en moins-value je suis
désolé quand tu devrais les bleus -
lille faute de ghinzu ci dessus qu'est
ce que je fais n'est d'accord après la
rafle et si je fais quoi non mais je
comprends très bien ce que tous les
plans si je dis sont là tu prends à
rallier même pas de 60 jeux médical où
elle ne fait plus dans
ces cas là plutôt bon non mais
avec beaucoup d'écouté
les cabanes j
non non je baise moi je veux dire que ce
qu'on est en train de faire là d'opposer
on n'arrivera jamais à novembre à raison
bras jamais d'accord parce que les
sommes sont extraordinaires des somme de
500 mille euros et un million d'euros
expliqué on en a parlé tous les deux et
on a à parler posément c'est le monde
des gens qui ont beaucoup d'argent mais
moi je ne plaindrai jamais quelqu'un qui
a décroché après avoir acheté des 50000
après avoir cédé bateau après avoir payé
des hélicoptères à 20000 euros les 20
minutes l'argent il fallait faire
attention mais je resterai ce métal et
travailler en hélico je ne
sais pas si
je veux dire un moment donné tu crois tu
pourras jamais tombés d'accord parce que
pour des gens tu empruntes 250 mille
trois cent mille quatre cent mille et
qui vont mettre 25 30 ans pour
rembourser ce que tu faire une semaine
c'est pas entendable et c'est comme ça
qu'il faut dix lots disponibles aussi
j'ai déjà entendu c'est pourtant garric
tous les montres well as combien quand
j'ai 70 ans n'a pas
vraiment eu à effacer go passé tu peux
croire et tout ce que tu veux
d'accord mais vous avez compris le fond
on tombera jamais d'accord si tu
commences à acheter des chevaux
ils sont belles les motos en même temps
il est très vert après toi moi moi moi
je vis maintenant je t'en prie moi moi
moi je suis consterné parce que disent
ils est un ignoble rageux qui ménage
dans ses racines de somme c'est
insupportable
quand et conduire en action tu veut
interdire les sortes les gens n'ont pas
le droit de gagner d'argent n'ont pas le
droit d'en dépenser première chose
deuxième chose arrête d'infantiliser les
gens tu ne sais pas ce que c'est que
gagner de l'argent il avait surmonté il
a eu des hauts des bas c'est très dur
parfois on dépense trop parfois on est
influencé par des gens qui nous font
dépenser beaucoup d'argent il s'est
retrouvé dans l'un viendrait suspects et
qui es tu pour l'infantiliser café thé
sont bons tirs mais heureusement pas
pardon arrête mais oui c'est
insupportable bien sûr utiliser ça bien
sûr il ya bien plus de problèmes c'est
bien tu va rajouter moi je bois les
paroles de guillaume aussi que avec
modération
comme d'habitude castaldi et de lormont
nous ont fait une master class et je
trouve que pardon mais gillet raymond et
daniel vous êtes une démagogie est d'une
mauvaise foi ces salles où les riches
regarde toi par exemple m'a dit laisse à
leur
légitime à ouvrir j'ai jamais dit c'est
fait par les gens
étudient benjamin y entendra jamais non
on s'entendra jamais j'ai pas dit qu'ils
étaient page estime fait attention si tu
veux me parler d'attaqué sur mes de
travail mais des trains
bon
retirer les mots que j'ai
laissé le fini de ce qu'il a dit
pour m avoir me reymond est ce que tu
vis aujourd'hui mieux qu'il ya quelques
années mieux qui apparaît au pmu ou qui
a trois bons et j'ai même te dire mais
aussi à deux ans quand j'étais à
découvert 428 euros avant qu'il me faut
ce travail est d'accord donc ça veut
dire que tu n y est plus heureusement
agréable confort confortable ouais ça
veut dire que tu peux peut-être payé tes
traite avec d'une fac tu veux te permet
de continuer ce que tu vois là ça me
permettait de changer de voiture ça
permet de sauver famille a pas de
voiture je peux changer vaudra peut-être
falloir est souvent roulé en voiture
quand il va voir la news je vais pas
venir à pied mais d'abord d'avoir le
même nom mais même malgré tout à un
train dit et c'est tant mieux et c'est
formidable tu consommes peut-être plus
aussi tu fais peut-être plus plaisir à
tes enfants pas forcément celle à la
nuance donc la vie chère que tu penses
que tu gères mieux c'est l'arche en jeu
j'ai remis mon âge j'ai un objectif de
servir que de yemma maison donc tu fais
un objet donc turin ça n'existe pas les
revers de fortune ou art explique ma
maman elle a été malade à 28 ans elle
est des lédoniens interdit bancaire du
jour je dis n'importe quoi il est malade
non mais oh combien les irrigants dire
des bêtises on est pas mal après mon
calcul il a toute sa tête alors je veux
bien que tu m'attaques avec mes deux
parties les salaires plomer ont pesé pas
mal à mon nom il est pas malade quel est
le salaire est dépensé et à la route sa
dette ce n'est peut-être pas
peut-être qu'il a substance précédent
lafaurie peut-être qu'il est devenu
allez vas-y jeter coup ils tous les
aides revenir finir il a toute sa tête
il est pris permettant sais pas je parle
avait utilisé une mascotte servait chez
alors 6 nuls 5 revers de fortune qu
est-ce que comme en quechua tu vois que
je dis je lui dirai droit dans les yeux
tu veux que je dis je dirais droit dans
les yeux vinci a merdé tu as fait la
connerie de taghjijt avait tout tu avais
tout et a merdé maintenant si je peux
t'aider c'est un revers et a pu doser
mais je pleurais pas sur toi je
t'aiderai si tu as besoin de quoi que ce
soit je t'aimerai les sommes énormes à
mesure je serai là et je ne ferai jamais
besoin de quoi que ce soit dans ma
mesure exactement qu'est ce que tu veux
et de turbo fr un plat arrivée au bras
de fer est jamais un gay moi je peux
être en galère c'est bien pour ça c'est
également fait que je l'aiderai c'est
bien pour ça je garde mon métier mais
d'accord mais j'irai jamais pleuré sur
maintenant il peut s'arrêter aussi les
baisses et ben si mon métier ça va sur
ses genoux
j'adore bras de jean j'irai travailler
si j'ai mon polo et on sait c'est
le charbon à gruissan parmi tous ceux
qui disent n'importe quoi c'est
guillaume à parce que mathieu benjamin
et géraldine c'est indécent on leur
parle de de la honte de se plaindre
quand on est riche et ils nous disent le
drame de ma maman le bébé société elo
drame de mon pistolet qu'est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on réponde à ça au moins
guillaume idée des conneries mais avec
des seins est
incroyable dit on sait que vous vous
plaignez vous faisiez vous plaindre
alors que des gens n'arrivent pas le 10
du mois à vivre et vous vous plaignez
pas ce qu on vous critique on s'en fout
nous gagner de l'argent on ne veut pas
que vous vous plaignez quand vous n'en
avez plus bas et soyez décent pour tous
les jours la page orange avait un
dixième place millième de ce que vous
avez vous rendez pas compte les gars
c'est le père connectés durant un mois
ce sera mieux que de dire n'importe quoi
aussi je peux me lancer ton truc comme
ça